bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 c'est l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale voici les titres de ce mardi 22
septembre la france audacieuse le nom de
ce rassemblement fondée en 2010 cette
part christian estrosi aujourd'hui à
saint germain en laye le maire les
républicains de nice a acté la
transformation de son courant mouvement
politique l'objectif faire entendre la
voix des territoires et peser dans le
débat public
deux cuillères les yvelines compte deux
centres de dépistage au qu'ovide 19
déployés par l' agence régionale de
santé ces sites ont pour objectif de
désengorger les laboratoires saturé en
ile de france
reportage attrape une ambition est de
réaliser jusqu'à 500 tests par jour et
puis de la musique pour adoucir ces
temps difficiles les halls factory
festival revenait pour une deuxième
édition à l'ile-aux-moines de
mantes-la-jolie trois jours de concert
au son notamment des caraïbes avec la
présence de jacob desvarieux cofondateur
du groupe kassav
c'était ce mardi matin depuis le
pavillon henri iv de saint germain en
laye le maire de nice christian estrosi
a transformé la france audacieuse en un
mouvement politique ce regroupement
d'élus locaux avaient été créés en 2010
est au lendemain de la victoire
d'emmanuel macro la présidentielle le
mouvement souhaite faire entendre la
voix des territoires et considère que
certains domaines régaliens comme la
sécurité et doivent être partagés entre
le pouvoir central et les élus locaux la
france
audacieuse s'appuie sur les maires des
grandes villes et s'ouvre désormais aux
militants écoutent et christian estrosi
interrogé par patrice carmouze
quel est le tremblement terre social
nous sanitaire qui vous conduit
aujourd'hui à le transformer en
mouvement
je crois que la crise il a co vide et
notamment dès le printemps dernier a
démontré quel point le gouvernement
était démuni et dépourvu dans des
compétences qui sont pleinement les
ciels et qui aux trois quarts pourtant
d'été assumé par les collectivités
locales à leur initiative sans esprit
polémique dans un mouvement d'unité
nationale mais qui a été un révélateur
le révélateur selon lequel aujourd'hui
si on le décentralise pas plus si on ne
partage pas plus de prérogatives entre
le gouvernement et les collectivités
nous ne répondrons pas dans les
principaux domaines où les français ont
des attentes que ça touche à
l'insécurité que ça touche à la
transition écologique que ça touche à la
cohésion sociale
ça pousse à l'emploi et une interview
qui sera à retrouver en intégralité dans
l'émission 7 8 l'hebdo c'est ce vendredi
sur tv 78 c'est donc à
saint-germain-en-laye que cette
assemblée générale de la france
audacieux se tenait aujourd'hui le maire
de la commune
arnaud péricard est l'un des porte
parole du mouvement son interview au
micro de patrice carmouze patrick
jacques de dixmude pour les moyens
techniques
arnaud péricard bonjour bonjour nous
sommes dans les salons du pavillon henri
iv et c'est ici que ce matin du 22
septembre a été modifiée si je peux dire
la france audacieuse qui était le
mouvement créé par christian estrosi qui
regroupait beaucoup de maires villes
importantes toulouse comme à reims comme
comme comme ça jamais allé en mouvement
politique qu'est ce que ça change de
devenir un mouvement politique
quand on a créé la france audacieuse il
ya déjà quelques années on a eu beaucoup
de demandes de citoyens qui avaient
envie de s'engager des chefs
d'entreprise certaines ont d'ailleurs
témoigné comme ce matin on se dit que
c'était un petit peu dommage de de
conserver cette approche là que console
j'ai lu qu'il fallait l'ouvrir à celles
et ceux qui avaient envie aussi de
porter la voix des des territoires alors
c'est ce qu'on a fait on éteint
mouvement un mouvement c'est quelque
chose de beaucoup plus large qu'un parti
politique moi je ne critique pas les
partis politiques je ne fais partie
d'aucun parti politique les partis ont
leur utilité les partis font partie de
l'adn démocratique de notre pays mais
pour autant je crois que certains
d'entre nous se sentent libres pas
d'adhérer à une formation politique qui
trouve peut-être ce pour quoi ils ont
voulu adhérer moi ce n'était pas mon cas
et dans la france et la suède
on a des hommes et des femmes élues
maintenant des citoyens engagés très
certainement qui peut-être ne retrouve
plus dans les formations politiques
traditionnelles ce qu'ils avaient
l'habitude d'y retrouver et ont envie de
participer différemment alors on voit
d'ailleurs que les partis politiques
sont en crise
pour la plupart d'autres que ça soit à
droite soit les rebelles
est ce que justement cette france des
territoires que vous représentez c'est
une alternative à l'engagement politique
non la prop un je ne sais pas si c'est
une alternative la france des
territoires c'est d'abord c'est la
france du bon sens voilà parce que le
territoire c'est avant tout le bon sens
et la france des solutions des solutions
qui sont testés à l'épreuve du terrain
voilà il ya rien de mieux pour tester ou
pour éprouver une solution que que le
terrain que deux
l'expérimenté et c'est ce que l'on fait
donc l'ambition de la france
audacieux c'est avant tout de proposer
des solutions de terrain est d'associer
des hommes des femmes qui sont dans
leurs démarches et on l'a vu aux
dernières élections municipales ont fait
preuve et ont fait acte de rassemblement
voilà et quand on est rassemblée on est
plus fort et quelle que soit sa couleur
politique
et quelles que soient ses opinions si on
se retrouve sur un tronc commun moi je
l' ai souvent dit quand j'ai mené mon
projet municipal au mois de mars dernier
je me contrefous de l'étiquette
politique des élus ou des hommes et des
femmes qui m'accompagne ce que je
voulais c'est qu'il croit en saint
germain qu'ils croient et qu'ils portent
et qu'ils défendent les projets que nous
avons défendu c'est la même chose sur la
france et dassieu zh on a une colonne
vertébrale en commun faire bouger nos
territoires et puis on est audacieux
ckoi l'audace l'audace c'est pas prendre
des risques insensés c'est au contraire
de faire bouger nos territoires
voilà c'est d'investir c'est de pouvoir
mobiliser l'emploi c'est de pouvoir
assurer protéger nos concitoyens
et justement cette france des
territoires est-ce que elle signifie
aussi que la france est encore un peu
trop centralisée trop étatique que trop
de choses se décident à paris il n'y a
plus il ya plus à faire la preuve la
démonstration du jacobinisme à la
française je crois que les mois dernier
démontre à longueur d'exemple quotidien
que ce jacobinisme on en crève dans ce
pays
alors je pense qu'il ya une toutefois
une prise de conscience et une prise de
conscience que les villes les
territoires étaient désormais avec des
acteurs de santé publique
et ça c'était nouveau nathalie sco vide
exactement la crise sanitaire a démontré
qu'on était des organisateurs on était
des logisticiens sur notre teint là où
certains d'entre nous et où certains
d'entre les citoyens pensaient que
l'état allait tout faire on s'est vite
rendu compte qu'il fallait de reposer
quelques parcs sur nos qualités nos
compétences nos bonnes volontés pour
pouvoir justement gérer cette crise
sanitaire donc cette crise du
jacobinisme à la française on est en
plein dedans parce que l'état n'a plus
les moyens
l'état doit se recentrer sur ses moyens
l'état de la plus les moyens de tout
faire et je crois que la solution c'est
les territoires c'est pas le problème
c'est les territoires en collaboration
avec des pas et est d'ailleurs christian
estrosi
dit il ya une égalité au fond entre
l'exécutif et puis les pouvoirs locaux
question quand même politique le maire
de nice qui est président de la
fondation christian estrosi a pris
partie personnellement pour la
candidature d'emmanuel macro est ce que
certains vont pas soupçonner sept
mouvements de la france audacieuse
d'être un sous marin pro macron pour les
élections présidentielles ne l'a jamais
été
voilà la particularité la france
audacieux c'est la liberté de ton la
liberté d'esprit et la liberté de pensée
nous sommes des hommes des femmes libres
et comme le disait christian estrosi
tout à l'heure nous n'avons qu'un seul
patron ce sont nos électeurs à qui nous
devons tout est absolument tout est
acquis nous sommes redevables de la
confiance qu'ils ont envers nous donc
non christian a dit ce qu'il a dit il le
pense qu on est un certain nombre à le
penser moi je le pense également gelé
toujours d'yves jeu l'assument
mais pour autant je crois que il est
trop prématuré pour parler d'une
élection présidentielle dont les
français se contrefiche
honnêtement aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est
parler présentiel l'enjeu c'est comment
on gère de cette crise comment on en
sort comment on protège au mieux les
français ils y compris dans cette crise
économique et sociale dans laquelle nous
sommes
commencé à entrer donc je pense pas que
ce soit en danger après que christian
estrosi prononce ce qu'il est ce qu'il a
prononcée sur emmanuel macron toujours
certain et c'est son droit
certains le ont validé ces propos de
deux n'ont pas validé écoutez la liberté
de ton c'est je crois que ce qui fait
aussi la force de certains seulement un
dernier mot sur saint germain en laye
parce que c'est pas la première fois que
vous appelez la france d'assister un peu
la capitale de la france audacieuse
vraiment et avec des proximités
géographiques on est en région
parisienne et c'est vrai qu'on a
beaucoup de collègues d'amis d'élus qui
devons à paris en semaine par des
rendez-vous que l'administration
centrale là aussi et donc c'est bien
plus commode pour tout le monde de se
retrouver moi j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
faire découvrir ma ville est depuis hier
tous les collègues maires qui sont venus
de cesse de me dire que cette ville est
magnifique
il devrait donc c'est j'ai beaucoup de
chance aujourd'hui d'en assumer
voilà là là cette direction et en être
le maire donc moi je suis très heureux
d'accueillir tout le monde et de faire
connaître ma ville merci infiniment
arnaud merci patrice toujours dans
l'actualité politique la démission
d'aurore bergé la députée des yvelines
laisse son poste de porte parole de la
république en marche elle l'a fait
savoir lors du bureau exécutif du parti
hier lundi la parlementaire a indiqué
cependant ce matin nos confrères de 7,8
actu qu'elle ne quittait pas pour autant
le mouvement présidentiel
aurore bergé était candidate pour la
présidence du groupe des marcheurs à
l'assemblée la semaine dernière ex ump
elle a rejoint la république en marche
en 2017 à magnanville on l'a appris hier
soir l'élection municipale a été
invalidée par le tribunal administratif
de versailles le maire divers gauche
michel lebouc avait été réélu avec 52 9%
des suffrages le 15 mars dernier soit 35
voix de plus que son adversaire nicolas
laroche
l'un de ces colistiers avaient alors
déposé un recours pour dénoncer une
vidéo à caractère promotionnel diffusé
lors de la cérémonie des voeux en début
d'année une vidéo qui est resté
accessible durant la campagne et michel
le bot à faire appel de cette décision
les yvelines toujours en zone de
circulation active du coronavirus de
décès supplémentaires ont été
enregistrés à l'hôpital dans le même
temps se faire attester est devenu très
difficile avec des laboratoires saturé
et une attente qui peut grimper parfois
jusqu'à une semaine pour avoir les
résultats c'est 200 c'est dans ce
contexte que l' agence régionale de
santé ouvre progressivement 20 centres
de dépistage dédié en ile-de-france et
en plus de mantes la jolie
l'un de ces sites est implantée à
trappes le reportage sur place de célia
gars de 100 go et mélanie potiche
quelques minutes d'attentes avant d'être
testé depuis lundi 21 septembre trappe
accueille un centre de dépistage et de
diagnostic qu'ovide d'ici trois semaines
le laboratoire espère réaliser 500 tests
quotidiens l'espoir qu'on a tous ses
essais à la volonté de la rs qui est
vraiment de faciliter l'accès aux
prélèvements dans des délais courts pour
les personnes prioritaires les personnes
prioritaires c'est vraiment celle qui
seraient susceptibles de propager
l'épidémie parce qu elles parce qu'elles
sont positives et parce qu'elles sont en
contact avec des gens cinq opérateurs de
saisie et trois infirmières permettent
un rendu de résultats sous 24 heures
le centre est ouvert six jours sur sept
il est accessible sur prescription
médicale ou pour les personnes
contactées par la rs ou la sécurité
sociale on a détecté hier qui est des
signes de covin mais en fait c'est une
rhinopharyngite comme tous les ans donc
pas précaution comme il est asthmatique
presse affaires le test du co vient
jeudi permanence et on a les résultats
assez rapidement donc moi ça m'intéresse
pour retourner en cours le plus possible
j'ai des symptômes j'ai eu des fièvres
voilà donc du coup j'ai par mesure de
précaution je suis venu faire le test
un deuxième centre est installé à
mantes-la-jolie d'ici quinze jours ce
sont vingt sites qui testeront sur toute
la région francilienne pour la semaine
du 7 au 13 septembre un peu plus de 6%
des personnes testées ont été déclarées
positives
le département est classé en zone active
de circulation du virus
le direction le port marly à présent
avec ce procédé innovant et écologique
une péniche installés sur la scène est
équipé d'un système de traitement des
eaux usées expérimental l'objectif c'est
d'améliorer la qualité de l'eau en vue
des jo de 2024 les précisions de michael
et demi d'euros depuis quelques semaines
une plateforme écologique a été
installée à côté de cette péniche au
port marly
ce système est basé sur la
phytoépuration il traite les eaux usées
de ce bateau qui sont déversées via des
tuyaux avec ce jardin flottant
en fait il ya une bascule d'une semaine
sur l'autre c'est à dire que pendant une
semaine le jardin est arrosé d'un côté
et pendant une autre semaine le jardin
est arrosé de l'autre côté lo travers la
filtration à sable et au fond c'est un
système pyramidal au fond on a on a une
pompe qui va ré arroser le jardin et
l'ensemble des deux jardins d'ailleurs
mais met doucement et renvoyer une
partie de ces eaux dans les filtres uv
une fois dans les filtres uv l'eau est
une nouvelle fois traité pour être
propre puis rejetés dans la seine
ce jardin d'assainissement peut être
utilisée par une famille de quatre à
cinq personnes
la vie les pilotes sur le projet il est
innovant l'enfance ou la phytoépuration
ça existe depuis très longtemps il est
innovant uniquement sur le fait qu'ils
soient sur une sur une barque et et qui
soit
à couple c'est à dire pour traiter des
bateaux des bateaux logement à terme si
les tests sont concluants ce dispositif
pourrait être généralisé sur le secteur
il n'est pas encore commercialisé pour
l'instant mais le prix de cette
plateforme avoisine les 15000 euros
et puisqu'on parle environnement cette
opération de ramassage des déchets
organisée par le département des
yvelines hier lundi elle se déroulait au
parc du peuple de l'herbe un espace
naturel sensible localisé à carrières
sous poissy ce site de 170 hectares
était une ancienne décharge transformé
par la collectivité
cette action dans le cadre de la semaine
européenne du développement durable a
été menée par les collaborateurs du
conseil départemental avec ceux de
carrières sous poissy partenaires de
cette opération les propos recueillis
par patrick jacques de dixmude c'est pas
quelque chose d'important c'est quelque
chose d'essentiel
parce que l'essence du département des
yvelines c'est la beauté la beauté de
ces espaces de ces espaces ruraux en
particulier de ces espaces verts de ces
espaces sylvestre de ces espaces
agricoles de ces espaces sur mer aussi
et donc le département est très engagé
dans la préservation et dans
l'amélioration de ces espaces il était
normal et moi je m'en félicite que nous
ayons pu avec le département mobiliser
nos agents publics qui ainsi porte une
valeur de responsabilité sociétale
à l'occasion de la semaine européenne du
développement durable dans le cadre du
world food day également d'apporter un
engagement citoyen encore plus fort en
procédant à une opération de nettoyage
c'est important on veut avoir une vie
propre agréable pour les se promener et
comme beaucoup d'enfants qui vivent à la
qui se balade tout ça beaucoup de
personnes un endroit propre
samedi c'était d'ailleurs le world clean
et des voisins le bretonneux l'événement
venait clôturer une semaine du climat
des habitants se sont réunis pour
nettoyer les rues de la commune près de
250 kg de déchets ont été ainsi ramassé
eléonore sinoquet et marie pas notera le
world food day s'invita voisins le
bretonneux cette opération citoyenne a
réuni 70 habitants mégots canettes
bouteilles paquets de cigarettes ou
encore papier tout a été ramassé et jeté
à la poubelle
je pense que garder la ville propre
c'est quelque chose qui doit être qui
doit rentrer dans l'adn de chaque vie si
noah et s'il faut passer par des
opérations coup de poing comme
comme celle ci est bien nous allons le
faire mais l'objectif est que vraiment
tout le monde se prennent en main et
nettoie au jour le jour les participants
petits et grands ont pris la mesure des
déchets dans leur ville grâce à cet
événement
j'ai amassé les déchets de mon quartier
comme ça la ville elle est propre et ça
me fait plaisir surtout on a détonné à
la fois deux du nombre de mégots qui
traînaient partout ça c'était vraiment
une calamité à la fin du ramassage près
de 250 kg de déchets ont été récoltés
ces opérations étaient organisés
également à montigny le bretonneux
maurepas villepreux ou encore plaisir et
puis c'était l'un des grands rendez vous
culturel de la rentrée les halls factory
festival revenait pour une deuxième
édition ali l'aumône de mantes-la-jolie
trois jours de concert avec une
programmation éclectique qui se
déroulait du vendredi 18 septembre
dimanche 20 septembre regarder ce sujet
[Musique]
la musique a résonné pendant trois jours
sur l'île aumône à mantes-la-jolie des
halls factory festival revenait pour une
deuxième édition
un premier rendez vous festif pour
beaucoup après le confinement est en
pleine crise sanitaire
c'est que ça fait du bien de retrouver
un peu de monde un peu de musique
après cette enquête un peu difficile
c'est vraiment un plaisir
on sait assez rassurant voit que tout le
monde respecte le corps du masque le
site est très agréable on a écouté un
très bon concert moment on est vraiment
ravi d'être sur ses fils
un événement qui a dû s'adapter au
contexte épidémique masque obligatoire à
l'intérieur du village spectateurs assis
les jauges dans très limité les
organisateurs ont dû faire face
également à des déprogrammations mais le
festival a pu bien se tenir
un grand bonheur un grand bonheur pour
les organisateurs parce qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé pour le public parce qu'il est
en manque de manifestations culturelles
et puis pour les artistes et interprètes
parce que ils n'ont quasiment pas eu
l'occasion et la possibilité de se
produire depuis des mois et encore moins
devant un public une programmation
éclectique avec à l'honneur les
instruments à vent dont le manteau est
un territoire référence pour leur
fabrication
ce samedi soir les festivaliers avaient
rendez vous avec la musique des antilles
de jacob desvarieux
[Musique]
à
le cofondateur de kassav se produisait
avec ses amis dont mario canonge au
piano une première scène pour lui depuis
son confinement en guadeloupe pendant
six mois
bah on jouait pour notre téléphone ans
filmé en train de jouer ou juste comme
ça quoi
c'est mieux qu'il ya des gens ça aussi
c'est compliqué c'est de jouer et de
voir que il ya peu de gens alors sont
pas venus on sait pas pour quelle raison
ceux qui sont venus entreprises est très
motivé le festival et olfactives a
accueilli 2700 personnes pour cette
deuxième édition le rendez vous devrait
revenir une nouvelle fois l'année
prochaine à mantes la jolie mais voilà
pour cet événement passé pour connaître
les prochains dans les yvelines je vous
invite dans quelques minutes à retrouver
le 7-8 culture c'est à partir de 18h30
sur tv 78 une émission présentée par
justine brasier voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de votre fidélité et
rendez vous dès demain pour une nouvelle
édition belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]